now for some perspective on the midterm
elections and more we turn to Bob Cusack
editor-in-chief of the hill Bob good
morning good morning a lot of you know
outcomes still uncertain actually all
over the country from from from the east
coast to the west coast but but the
picture of four days after the election
is starting to become clearer and it
looks like now in the house as many as
35 seats or more the Democrats could
have flipped right yeah I mean this is
the biggest and I would call it away you
would call it I would call it a wave in
the house because this is the most
democratic pickups since Watergate this
is bigger than 2008
it's bigger than 2006 so now I know some
Democrats were disappointed they didn't
do better in the Senate but the house
was a victory no doubt about it any
reasoning why in the Senate it didn't
fall the same way well you know it's
just a matter of the battlegrounds that
the map was very Republican friendly in
the Senate and and in the in the house
was more the suburbs and that's where
Republicans and Trump got beaten a lot
of staging going on a lot of peering in
the contest over the actual ballots in
Florida in Arizona in these hotly
contested races just when you think
about like people saying there was
rampant fraud and elect elected
officials saying my goodness we we
shouldn't count every vote right is that
a slippery slope it is and I think the
voters are gonna get tired of it I mean
we had the election and it's not going
to be over for quite some time so I
think the PR games the spinning it's
interesting in Florida I mean this is
Rick Scott he's the governor he has bend
Florida officials and some Republicans
are calling on him to do that in Broward
County that remains to be seen how
important is that recount in Florida to
both parties very important the
Republicans are gonna have control the
Senate no doubt about it it's either
gonna be one two or probably three seats
but what if there's another Supreme
Court nomination what if that
nominations controversial how many votes
do Republicans have to play with so and
then it's like someone like susan
collins who basically was a decider on
Brett Kavanaugh really has less power
if Republicans pick up a couple more
seats you know the president after the
election was touting it as a Republican
victory was it for his agenda at least
and not for his agenda because he's not
going to get anything I think that he
really wants a republic
slub he's not gonna get that 10%
middle-class tax cut um it was a split
decision I think he did a very good job
in getting his base out in the Senate
races in the red states we even heard
anything about immigration
since the elect that's right that's
right that's exactly right so I think it
was a split decision but for his agenda
anything that gets through Congress now
it's got to be bipartisan we want to
talk about Matt Whittaker quickly the
acting Attorney General already a fight
over him where do you think that's
headed well I think Democrats going to
try to craft some legislation that would
protect the robert muller Pro but that
the things the more probe is toward the
end now the question is what are we
gonna see what are the public going to
see the report has to be filed to DOJ so
Whittaker decides whether that becomes
public but then House Democrats could
have a hearing and they could say they
could compel it to come forward so it's
a big deal but I also think the mullet
probe is gonna wrap up pretty soon so
much to talk about
exactly I'm cue stick thanks for joining
us thank you